Hi today, we're doing
something a little different.
Steve Kaufmann here, of course,
along with my son, Mark.
And for those of you, for those of you
who don't know, mark is the CEO of LingQ.
He's the one who decides
what we're going to do.
He organizes people on five
continents that work for LingQ, you
know,  programmers, designers and...
a great team of people and so forth.
And, uh, so I'm very excited today
to be able to interview Mark or he
interviews me and we talk about LingQ
5.0, which has finally finally launched.
It was launched on the mobile
app a little while ago and now
it's launched on the browser.
Mark, could you maybe introduce some
of the things that are in LingQ 5.0?
Oh, sure.
I mean, obviously we just finally
pushed our web version a few days ago.
And so it's obviously, there's been a
lot of, uh, discussion on the forum.
We had the iOS of course
version has been available for
probably a month and a half now.
Android also has been released more or
less recently to most users, uh, in the,
in the, at the same time as the web app.
So, um, there are a lot
of comments on the forum.
Some people really like it.
Some people are having trouble, uh,
getting used to it, uh, as always
happens when, when changes are
made to any, any software product.
Um, obviously we're aware that, um, for
those people who really liked the way link
4.0 worked, uh...some love the change.
Others are wondering why we made changes.
And so we thought it'd be a good
opportunity to explain why we did
some of the things we did and what
some of the benefits are to version
five that, that probably may not all
be, um, obvious right at first blush.
Well, what, what I'd like to start in
with is I am very enthusiastic about
LingQ 5.0, and I'm more of a user.
Mark is the one who put a lot of
thought together with his team
and do what we should have there.
What I see with LingQ 5.0 is it's sort of
like a new start for LingQ it's, it's a
more exciting way of getting at content,
better organized, um, more motivating.
A platform which allows LingQ
to develop new functions.
It's it's a totally new product.
That's not immediately obvious to people.
So, um, I'm excited about it, but I think
it would be worthwhile to hear from Mark
in some detail about some of the things
that are there, but bear in mind that
you have to get in there and use them.
Overcome the strangeness of new features
in order to fully appreciate the extent
to which this is really a much more
powerful way of learning languages
without realizing that you're learning.
And I, that's what I
take away from LingQ 5.0.
Uh, absolutely.
And I think when we started to, to
make LingQ 5.0 in effect, uh, worth
pointing out that version five, unlike
version four is, is, um, the core
components of LingQ on the web were
completely rewritten from scratch,
which we haven't done in a long time.
And, and both the mobile apps were also
more or less rewritten from scratch.
So, uh, significantly different than
when we went from version three to
version four, uh, and, and a big part
of the reason why was we, we wanted
to have a more stable platform that,
uh, that was easier to develop upon.
I mean, the fact is that LingQ's been
around a long time and we've had a lot
of versions and, uh, you know, as you
evolve and iterate there ends up, it
ends up being tougher and tougher to,
to improve upon what's there before.
Things have been built on top
of other things, which were
built on top of other things.
And so at a certain point, we
needed to have a fresh start.
Um, when we then went to do that, it gave
us an opportunity to look at a lot of the
things that we have done over the years,
uh, and to try and kind of streamline
things and, um, make things clear, both
functionality wise and in the way that
some of the things work on the site.
So I know that one of the things
you're quite excited about these
days is the coins, uh, and how
are our goal for maintaining your
streak is no longer measured, uh,
or set in, in terms of LingQs.
But in fact, set in terms of
coins, you can earn coins by
creating LingQs, moving words up in
status, um, reading and listening.
So there, there are many more ways of
earning coins and, and so that, uh,
well I'll, maybe I'll let you continue.
Well I mean any of you who have followed
my YouTube channel you know that I often
use this metaphor of the, uh, racing
dogs who chase a mechanical rabbit.
And anytime you can create
something that people are keen
on doing for whatever reason...
uh, so they're chasing this thing.
And as a result, they're learning.
So uh, to me having coins, which you
can't, you can't buy anything at the
grocery store with the coins, but
these are points that accumulate.
And in the past, you know, if I was only
getting credit for say creating LingQs,
but I was going through a period where I
wasn't creating new LingQs because I was
reviewing old material, or I was doing
a lot of lists, or I was moving some of
my status two or three words to known.
Uh, I was getting no credit for that.
Whereas now it's sort of merged into
one single unit that we follow coins.
And so if I had, as I have now done,
uh, I'll go into my vocabulary list and
I will select out status three words
and I'll move a lot of them to known.
And I get lots of coins for doing that.
And whereas I'm normally washing
the dishes and listening now I'm
also getting coins for listening.
And in fact, I don't know all
the details, but a wider range
of activities generate coins.
And so you follow your progress
and your activity level, but
it's not limited to just a couple
of things like creating LingQs.
And I find that strangely motivating.
The coins is one area where we
try to, to make things easier
to understand for people.
Um, you know, in, in the past
we've had the activity score.
We've had the activity apple,
we had LingQs target for
your streak, we had coins.
So, as I say, in terms of simplification,
what we've done is we've, we've now
gotten rid of the activity score,
which used to be the measure of how
active you were for the last 30 days.
Uh, and that determined the color of
your activity apple, uh, we've done away
with the apple and that activity score.
And instead we're, we're
just gonna use coins.
So we're again, trying to simplify.
Based on the number of coins you've
earned in the last 30 days, your
streak indicator will also change color
like the activity apple did before.
So just a small example of, of a place
where we tried to kind of make things
simpler because the reality is for
new users, there was a lot to learn.
And, and so, yeah, we, you know,
the danger in software is always to
keep building stuff and new features
and feature creep, as they say.
And so here, we're trying to, trying
to declutter a bit, um, make things
less intimidating for new users.
And at the same time, trying to, as you
say, have more activities count towards
exactly the measure that, that, that,
that you're trying to move the needle on.
I mean, it's, to me it's so important
to, to be active with the language.
That's the number one thing.
I mean, we will progress more quickly
at some times, or for some languages
than with others, but if we're, if we're
active, we're going to get somewhere and
enabling, sort of, encouraging us to be
engaged in a number of different kinds
of activities, and we'll see later how
it's become easier now to do a variety
of things where you are engaged with the
language, moving forward in the language,
getting credit for this and your coins.
And I think that's going to motivate
more people and keep them more
active with sort of less frustration.
So I'm quite excited about that.
We've also made some changes to the
way we track listening and reading.
Um, so we're no longer...
it used to be that you had to finish
a, a reading, a lesson, and then you
got credit for having read it one time.
And just like when you were listening
to the audio, you got credit.
If, and when the audio file
finished playing, you got credit
for having listened to at one time.
Whereas now we're tracking in real time.
So, so anytime you listen,
it's being tracked.
And if you listen for 30 seconds,
then you'll see 30 seconds added
to your listening, uh, right away.
You know, obviously when you're
measuring coins for your daily streak,
there's no point giving you credit
for listening to, uh, uh, or reading
a lesson when it takes you a week.
And we give you credit for having read
it on the seventh day that doesn't
help you on the previous six days.
Uh, it doesn't contribute
to your coins goal.
So we track in real time now.
One thing that has improved is the
ability to time-stamp in sentence mode.
And so I've been listening to
this, uh, you know, in sentence
mode, this Jordanian, uh, you know,
Levantine Arabic cartoon series.
And very often, you know, it just
seems like they cut off, you know,
at the beginning of the, whatever
it was, it seems like it should
have started half a second earlier.
It should have gone on a half a
second later or two a second later.
Uh, every time I listen to it, I'm
listening to it over and over again,
in order to capture just when that
particular audio that corresponds to
that sentence, you know, what is the
actual audio snippet that I want there?
And every time I listen, I'm listening.
And so, again, it's this idea that I'm
sort of induced to, to get involved in
these other activities, for whatever
reason, because I want to capture the
accurate sound file, which by the way,
anyone who comes after me will benefit
from, but as I'm doing that, I listen to
it three or four times, I'm listening.
And so it's just another example of how
we do things for a variety of reasons.
But the net effect is we're more active
in the language and we're learning.
And the fact of the matter is changes that
we made related to timestamping uh, here,
we're talking about editing a sentence.
So when you're in sentence mode,
there's an option to edit the sentence.
Uh, that in itself I think
is a significant improvement.
And maybe particularly for like,
I'm studying Japanese right now so
particularly when you're studying
Japanese, you, you very often want to
edit incorrect word splits uh, something
that can't be helped in the end.
Um, so it's easy.
Edit that sentence, make a quick change,
save that sentence, keep LingQing.
Whereas before you had to edit the
lesson, wait for that page to load,
find the spot in the text where you
want to fix that, uh, split, save it,
make your way back to where you were.
Uh, so that's, a small change that I
think will have a significant impact.
And there, again, it allows us to
provide a better system, once we've
made the edit, a better system of
timestamping, which has many benefits.
And that was something that for years,
people were asking for "hey, and you
have the, the text match the audio
file, move along with the audio in
some way so that we can follow along
and, and obviously to do that is a
lot of effort requires timestamping.
Now in the meantime, technology has
come a long way where a lot of the
time, now we can either import the
timestamps from services like YouTube,
or there are tools that will...
compare the audio file with the
text and automatically timestamp.
And we've implemented some of those
uh, in the new version as well.
And then these tools then allow, allow
you to fine tune those timestamps or
in some cases, some languages, Japan,
Japanese, as an example, some languages
don't have the automated timestamping
so there at least give you a better
tool for manually timestamping lessons
than some, some users, some content
providers will want to do that.
Just an improvement and it, what
it, what it does is it lets us...
for example, obviously more easily play
that audio snippet in sentence mode.
So instead of text to speech
audio in sentence mode, you're
getting that timestamp segment
from the actual audio file.
And then, then one of the major new
innovations, as well as this listening
mode, which is, uh, an audio playing
mode, where if you, if you click the audio
player, there's an option in the audio
player to expand that view and, and, uh,
see the listening mode, which is very...
functions, very similarly to a lyrics
mode and a music app like Apple Music
or Spotify so that you'll see the
text of what you're listening to.
And the text, if the timestamping
is correct, the text will actually
highlight and move along as you listen.
So those are significant improvements,
all kind of related to this
timestamping sentenced editing.
A lot of these changes that we've
made all kind of impact in many ways.
There's lots of fun things that like, I
discovered that in sentence mode, which
I use a lot, especially in Persian and
Arabic, which I still find very difficult
to read lo and behold, someone has gone
in there and put translations in...
I was doing this Arabic series,
in Korean and Turkish, which are
both languages that I have studied.
So I not only hear this in Arabic and
then I see the English translation.
I, if I'm interested, I can
also turn them off, but I can
see uh, Korean and the Turkish.
Now, if someone puts in a
French translation, I'll
see the French translation.
Well, the reality is you'll only see
those, if you edit that sentence.
Oh, well, how did I see that?
Anyway?
Cause you edited the sentence.
If you're, if you're...
I believe dictionary language is set to
Turkish, then you'll see the Turkish.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Anyway, I saw three of them
anyway, surprises, whatever.
Okay.
What else have you got?
The first thing that will strike people
when they open LingQ five is, is, um, that
the library looks considerably different.
And we, we actually felt that
the old library was in a bit of
a weak point for version four.
Uh, we, we didn't do a great job or at
least in our new version, we feel like
we do a much better job of surfacing
the content, more, better content, uh,
to keep people engaged, to help people
make sure they, to make sure people
can, can find content more easily.
Um, finding content they like, and we
have, uh, we have far more, uh, links
to external sources of content because
obviously the importing feature, which
is a very powerful, uh, component of,
of LingQ is, is great if you know where
to find content, but it's not always
that easy, especially if, if you know,
you're just starting out or, or yeah...
the ability to, for us to source content
is just much greater than for individuals.
We have, not that we're doing it
ourselves, I mean, many members of
our community are great at sourcing
content and sharing that information
on the forum with us, obviously.
Uh, we have our volunteer volunteer
librarians, and we have our, of course
our own internal content people.
And everybody together is working hard
to find the best content out there so
that we can present it in our library
and our new format, um, which...
we feel looks a lot nicer and presents
things a lot better and, and then
also has much more variety of content.
And, and then more of these
external sources of content.
There are some issues we've discovered.
We had a long beta, you know, a QA testing
period, but there's so many different
browsers and monitor sizes that there
have been some issues, uh, which we're
going to go about resolving and in the
lesson page, uh, and you know, again,
what makes me excited is we've rewritten
it all as Mark says, and we have a
platform now where we can not only twig
any issues that are, you know, have been
identified in our new, uh, LingQ 5.0, but
the ability now to develop further, uh,
with new ideas and taking advantage of,
uh, all the different things that are out
there that are making language learning
more fun, more motivating for people,
less resistance, less frustration, less
charge around trying to look for content.
Um, yeah, it's exciting
for me it's exciting.
Oh for sure.
And I mean, a big focus for us was,
was trying to simplify with this
update, try to reduce the clutter,
make things less intimidating.
There are, obviously there are users
who aren't that happy with some of
the changes because they were used to
the previous interface and some, some
elements of it were more convenient.
Uh, there are other elements
that were less convenient.
In the end I think, you know, one of
the, one of the big benefits when you
talk about improving things is, is
as we move forward, we'll just, we,
we intend to introduce more and more
customization so that people can set
up their library, set up their reader,
how, how they would like to see it.
Uh, and, and so that it's no
longer a one size fits all.
Uh, so more and more customization,
which I think should, should, uh,
hopefully resolve a lot of the, um, uh,
issues that some users are reporting.
I think as people get in and they discover
things like, I mean, we could go on
forever, like the multiple playlist, a
whole bunch of other things like that.
I suspect we will get more and
more requests for customization.
And I guess in the new platform, we'll
be better able to accommodate that.
I mean, we get those requests all the
time and had them for version four too.
And we could, we just felt like we can't
keep making those kinds of improvements
in version four, uh, on that platform.
Just too restrictive and
too, too time consuming.
That was a big driver for
the changes that we made.
And yeah, there are lots of other
things there, there, the, the
multiple playlists is something that
people have asked for forever, or
at least a way to organize content.
So now you can, you want to organize
your, um, songs into a songs playlist.
Or, or whatever you want to do, uh,
you can, you can use the playlist
to play the audio, but you can
also just use the playlist to
organize, uh, lessons and courses.
It's up to you.
But there, there you have a tool
for organizing your library.
Um, in addition, even the dark mode,
light mode, um, something we've
been asked for for a long time.
So, so that is there.
Uh, which, and looks great.
I really liked it the
way the dark mode works.
I have it set to automatically switch
based on our computer settings.
The light mode is set to be on
during the day in dark mode at night.
By the way, importing is a
lot easier in the new system.
I do a lot of importing and I
find it's a lot more convenient,
lot more, more intuitive.
You mean that the actual import page page?
Yeah, we tried to clean that up too.
I think it's much simpler.
I mean, we had a lot of functionality
built on top of functionality
in the old, in the old view.
One thing that's, that's not yet in
the web version, but is an iOS and...
I can't remember if it's on
Android yet or not, but will be on
all  platforms, and that is the,
uh, full text, text to speech.
Uh, so any lessons that you import that
have no audio, you will, you will be
able to generate at least a text to
speech, audio version of that lesson.
So that'll be, that'll be great.
Yeah besides that, I guess I, you know,
small things in the reader, there's that
words pop up, which shows when you first
opened a lesson, or if you click away
a word which has a, you shows a list of
all your blue words shows a list of...
Oh, yeah.
There's all kinds of...
...of your, your LingQs and actually
shows you a list of all the words in the
lesson, which we've never shown before.
So there, you can actually see all the
known words that you've told us that you
know, that you never created LingQs for.
So, so that was something that people
actually asked us for all the time.
Yeah.
That's very handy.
...which we've never provided before.
So just interesting.
And you can see, you know, what,
what, what words are there,
what statuses they have, which
words you, you told us you knew.
Uh, yeah.
Anyway, there's lots of
little things there and...
I encourage people to use different...
now, especially since you get
credit for it, in terms of
coins, go to the vocab section.
You know, one of the things that I
like to do is go there and select
all my status three words, and I can
look at them by frequency so that
the most frequent words will show up.
Or I can look at them in
alphabetical order, which even for
Persian or Arabic, there was some
kind of an alphabetical order.
And that has the advantage that you'll
see related words, words that have, you
know, uh, the same prefix sort of thing.
They'll show up 3, 4, 5, 6 words
that are related to each other.
It all helps.
And as you're doing this and maybe moves,
moving some words from status one to
status two or status two to three, or to
known you're getting coins all the time.
So I encourage people to really
explore all the things that are there.
If you don't, if some of the
favored features that you find
are not as convenient for you in
the new LingQ 0.5, let us know.
But at the same time, please be patient.
I think what we've done here is create
something with tremendous opportunity
for development going forward.
So please take the time to
explore it and let us know your...
I mean, I think, uh, the reality
is that that we've been using,
you know, LingQ five internally.
Uh, you know, I don't know...
It's been a year.
I haven't used LingQ four for over
a year on iOS, on Android and web.
I've Simply...
it's just...
Much better.
I don't want to be in version four.
And, and so, but, but obviously I
I've been exposed to it a lot longer
and have used it longer, but there's,
there's, there's you end up in
version four, uh, and it just feels...
it's just less it's it's it's
it's version five is, is, is a
bigger, is a big step forward.
And, and we know you're going to love it.
Like we do.
And look forward to obviously hearing
your comments and your thoughts on some
of the things we talked about today.
Very exciting time for us...
Absolutely.
... here at LingQ and we're
really happy to have it launch
because it did take us a while.
But as, as Steve said, we're set up for
for further enhancement now and looking
forward to what the future will bring.
Thank you.
Thank you for listening
through this description and
please enjoy the new LingQ.
Thanks everyone.